[Musica]
[Applauso]
immaginate di trovarvi da soli con 20
chili di zaino sulle spalle state
combattendo da ore contro pioggia e
vento lungo una ferita impervia
scivolando frequentemente nel fango e
con i sud ora che vi si congela sulla
pelle
nell'ottobre del 2015 stavo
attraversando da nord a sud
l'isola di skye in scozia e mentre
percorrevo la filata cresta del trotter
niger mi trovavo esattamente in quelle
condizioni
impiegai quasi un'ora per montare la
tenda a causa del forte tempo per poi
letteralmente svenire dentro sacco a
pelo per la stanchezza
quando mi svegliai il mattino seguente
trovai tutto quanto fradicio perché
avevo accidentalmente mondato la mia
tenda all'interno di una conca che si
era ovviamente allagata durante la notte
uscì dal mio riparo chiaro quindi
tremendamente irritato perché sapevamo
quanto possa essere critico trovarsi in
un ambiente selvaggio con il proprio
sacco a pelo bagnato senza aver la
possibilità di asciugarlo ero quindi
forse nel peggior stato d'animo
possibile quando mi voltai casualmente
verso la strada percorsa al giorno
precedente e di questo ci sono momenti
immagini che si imprimono nella nostra
memoria
la maggior parte in modo del tutto
inconsapevole quel giorno e vi però la
certezza che non avrei mai scordato
questi colori questa vista superba quel
giorno forse non capite il tutto la
rilevanza di quell istante di quanto
quel paesaggio avrebbe cambiato il corso
della mia vita mi sento felice
ecco cosa successe e per la prima volta
dopo tanto tempo
fui felice senza sentirmi in colpa
fui felice di essere lì e di essere solo
sono quasi certo che fu questo paesaggio
a far nascere dentro di me il desiderio
di dedicarmi altro ai kings e di farlo a
tempo pieno
vi starete chiedendo che cos'è il tuo
hiking ai kings è un termine inglese che
possiamo tradurre con escursionismo
mentre le troupe è una contrazione
gergale che significa attraverso scopo
del tuo ai kings e quindi attraversare
territori il più possibile selvaggi e
incontaminati
in totale autonomia camminando per
settimane mesi
percorrendo centinaia migliaia di
chilometri
il biker necessita innanzitutto di un
equipaggiamento oltre a leggendo si
impara a riconoscere il superfluo perché
più importanti viaggiare leggeri
piuttosto che morire di fatica sotto il
peso del comfort e deve anche a prendere
tutta una moltitudine di nozioni che gli
permettono di sopravvivere quando si
trova lontano dalla civiltà
in questo modo con il passare del tempo
e il crescere dell'esperienza si riesce
a percorrere un lungo trike con uno
zaino ben più piccolo e leggero di
quello usato da molti escursionisti
durante una gita di mezza giornata in
montagna
il tuo hiking ci permette in questo modo
di comprendere quante cose
effettivamente superflue ci circondano e
di quanto siamo ormai dipendenti da i
comfort e dalle tecnologie presenti
nelle nostre case e nelle nostre città
durante un trike possono avvenire anche
situazioni e avventurose di quelle che
fanno accelerare i battiti cardiaci e
magari anche emergere nostre capacità
che non credevamo di avere ma in massima
parte nel tuo ai kings si cammina e
quando si percorrono lunghe distanze
ogni giorno con il paesaggio che muta
continuamente di fronte ai nostri occhi
noi siamo forse nella situazione
migliore possibile per ragionare per
riflettere e per qualcuno come è stato
per me anche ritrovare se stesso la
traversata dell'isola di sky
fu solo la prima esperienza dietro ai
per me era un novizio totalmente
impreparato affrontai quell'avventura
come fosse una specie di fuga dall
angoscia un'angoscia seguita un evento
drammatico che l'idea come protagonista
iniziai dopo aver visto che quella
avventura mi fece bene iniziai a
combattere la depressione e gli attacchi
di panico lanciando mine avventure via
via sempre più impegnative in poco meno
di un anno mi sono trovato a dormire a
meno 20 gradi
tra le vette del giura francese con la
sola protezione di un tar un telo
impermeabile sono scampato al whiteout
degli altipiani norvegesi una tempesta
di neve con visibilità zero e
temperature polari sono affondato fino
al petto nelle sabbie mobili delle
highland scozzesi sono finito dentro a
un lag in lapponia mentre cercavo di
attraversarlo con una barchetta a remi
nel bel mezzo di una tempesta ma no non
ho solamente rischiato la mia vita
il tracking mi ha anche permesso di
vedere posti meravigliosi incredibili
che solo pochissime persone hanno avuto
il privilegio di ammirare ho avuto il
piacere di addormentarmi al calar del
sole e svegliarmi all'alba sentendomi
perfettamente riposato nonostante i 55
km percorsi il giorno precedente
ho avuto la compagnia della danza
dell'aurora boreale per ore sopra la mia
testa ho scoperto qualità di me che non
credevo di avere di essere più forte e
più abili di quanto non pensasse ho
riscoperto il piacere di risolvere
problemi immediati del tutto superflui
nella vita quotidiana di città come può
essere accendere un fuoco sotto la
pioggia quando fa freddo o purificare
dell'acqua
costruire un riparo ritrovare la via con
la bussola quando si realizza di essersi
persi tutto questo grazie ad una sola
qualità
il coraggio ma non parla del coraggio in
senso classico
il coraggio di dare una svolta drastica
la propria vita
il coraggio di mettere in tutto quanto
in discussione il coraggio di provare ad
uscire dalla propria con forgione
se ripenso a come era la mia vita anche
prima di quell'evento che la sconvolse
posso definirla come una specie di
galleggiare non andavo a fondo ma
nemmeno riuscivo a delle barre mila dove
avrebbero potuto portarmi i miei sogni
continuavo la mia vita da ricercatore in
laboratorio credendo di avere più cose
da perdere che da guadagnare
abbandonando la mia routine quotidiana
quanto mi sbagliavo e ho dovuto
attendere che il mondo mi crollasse
addosso per rendermene conto
il tuo hiking mi ha permesso di
comprendere quanta meraviglia ci sia
questo mondo e che niente avrebbe dovuto
tarp armi le ali distruggermi i sogni o
addirittura a spingermi a mettere
termine alla mia vita in solitudine
senza l'influenza dei media delle altre
persone anche di quelle che ci vogliono
bene possiamo riscoprire possiamo
riscoprire quello che conta davvero per
noi quello che ci fa stare bene quello
che sentiamo davvero di amare per
qualcuno di voi che magari è la stessa
ricerca in questo senso il tracking
potrebbe essere d'aiuto
allora cosa state aspettando potete
provare a preparare lo zaino studiate
bene il percorso e partite sarà sarà il
vento a suggerirvi le risposte
il silenzio a indicarmi una via sarà la
natura stessa a mostrarvi verso dove
volete andare voglio lasciarvi con un
invito siate anche voi coraggiosi non
abbiate paura del cambiamento
mettete in discussione le vostre
sicurezze e le vostre certezze
cercate quel sentiero che possa portare
ad una realtà in grado di contenere i
vostri sogni
e se non riuscite a vederlo questo in
chiaro beh tracciate lo voi perché ogni
twyker conosce la gioia di arrivare a
destinazione
seguendo una via che solo lui ha
percorso il sentiero
grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]